- [Instructor] We're told we know
that five times three is equal to 15.
Yep, that's true.
So which of the following
statements are also true?
And it says to choose two answers.
So pause this video and see
if you can work through that.
All right, now let's go
through them one by one.
So this first one says,
"Three is a multiple of 15."
Now, in order for three to be
able to be a multiple of 15,
that means that we can multiply 15
by some whole number to get to three.
But a multiple of 15,
we're thinking 15, 30, 45,
it's not gonna be three.
What whole number can I
multiple 15 by to get three?
If I multiply 15 by
one, I'm already at 15.
So this is not going to be our choice.
And since it say pick two answers, well,
we might be able to figure out it's these.
But let's just read them
to make sure that they make sense.
15 is a multiple of three.
So that means I can multiply
three times some whole number
to get to 15, and we know
what that whole number is.
It's five.
They tell us right over there.
Five times three is 15.
So 15 is a multiple of three.
15 would also be a multiple
of five 'cause I can
multiply five by the whole
number three to get to 15.
So I like this choice.
Five is a factor of 15.
Well, a factor, factors of a number
are numbers that you can multiply together
to get that number.
So five is a factor of 15,
and three is a factor of 15,
because five times three is 15.
So this one is also true.
It would've also been true
if they'd said three is a factor of 15,
or if they'd said 15
is a multiple of five.
Any of those would have
been true statements
based on what we know, that
five times three is equal to 15.